jetzt ganz oft den namen friedrich merz
wieder gehört über ihn diskutiert
offenbar hat friedrich merz ein weiteres
problem als das über das paul gerade
gesprochen hat offenbar hat ein problem
bei jungen wählern sagst du bekommst du
drauf guten abend
wir hatten gestern das statement auch
hier bei uns bei bild live von dem fdp
bundestagsabgeordneten konzert in cooler
und zwar gesagt man sollte bei friedrich
merz bedenken dass den unter 30 in
deutschland keiner mehr kennt
bei bild ist er uns immer wichtig mit
den menschen zu reden
das gilt insbesondere für das ressort wo
ich arbeite mit social media team und
deswegen haben wir die menschen gefragt
über die hier einfach gesprochen wurde
damit wir nicht nur eine vage idee haben
sondern dass auch wirklich belegen also
vor einigen die jungen leute kennt ihr
friedrich merz ja oder nein was das
ergebnis genau wir sehen hier im
hintergrund das video mit dem wir
gefragt haben auf der plattform step
chatten das besondere ist dass wir dort
zu 90 prozent der userinnen und user die
wir haben dort unter 24 jahren sind also
genau die kernzielgruppe für die wir
reden und zwar kennen 22 friedrich merz
dementsprechend die überwiegend der
schlagende mehrheit von 78 prozent haben
gesagt nein ich kenne nicht friedrich
merz warum warum warum ist das so lese
keine zeitung haben die sich völlig
ausgeglichene warum ist es vorbei
gegangen an so vielen unter 25-jährigen
wer friedrich merz ist ich glaube nicht
dass es wirklich am alter von friedrich
merz liegt sondern es liegt an der
politik die er macht friedrich merz das
betrifft er gesagt viele deutsche
politiker die durch die medien gehen die
in zeitungen sind die inhalte die dort
besprochen werden sind nicht die inhalte
die junge generation und hier im
vergleich zu unter 30-jährigen irgendwie
betreffen das sind ganz klar die themen
umwelt ist ein sozialer gerechtigkeit
und die themen finden dort nicht immer
straße friedrich merz könnte das ändern
konnte seine bekanntheit auch bei jungen
w lan
erhöhen indem er einfach auf andere
themen an spielt genau gleichzeitig
glaube ich nicht dass es einfach nur ein
wickeltisch zu sagen okay dann mache ich
jetzt social media für friedrich merz
ist auch auf instagram zum beispiel und
veröffentlicht dort sachen aber dort
genauso wie im echten leben geht um ein
bisschen authentizität und diese themen
die man dort hat vernünftig zu vertreten
dass man eben daran glauben kann dass
sie für uns gesprochen nutzer aber eben
auch die zukünftigen wählerinnen und
wähler dort finden zu dem mann zu der
frau kann ich ihnen vertrauens werden
und stehen die anderen kandidaten genau
so schlecht da also ist dass insgesamt
das bild von allen führenden in der cdu
im moment dass kaum jemand sie kennt
oder ist dein eindruck dass die deutlich
bekannter sind als friedrich merz und
der wirklich da das schlusslicht ist ich
glaube dass es ein großes strukturelles
problem in der deutschen politik ist
dass die deutsche politik nicht junge
menschen ab holt das muss nicht jetzt
ein großes problem zur nächsten wahl
werden aber auf die nächsten jahr
gesprochen die jetzt 16 17 jährigen
werden irgendwann wähler und werden
irgendwann ihre stimme geben können
und dann kann das ein problem werden
deswegen ist auch das häufig
verschriebene video von rizzoli
zerstörung der cdu da ist etwas wahres
dran nämlich die politik erreicht diese
jungen menschen nicht und das muss sich
deutlich ändern
danke morton wenn's weg aus der
bild-redaktion social media neue
plattformen danke für diese exklusiven
zahlen zu 40 märz und wir machen
fliegenden wechseln